[Music]
your characters a little bit of a
villain you know a Camille in real life
I do know Camille reality check little
rats you can work as hard as you like
you can train 24 hours a day but you
will always be nothing I feel like there
are so many snobby ballerinas in life
and I've had to deal with a lot of mean
dancers but I guess my character is just
an example of what not to be in the
dance scene because as a dancer
everyone's like competing for the same
spot so I kind of just have to let
people take their turns and not be a
snob and how do you deal with those
girls just block them out like it like I
just act like they don't matter at all
and you know what their opinion means
one thing but maybe it's just them and
not to anyone else you know I can't let
one person get in my way so now your
movie careers blowing up right now I got
to ask you this new SIA project you told
me it'll be unlike anything we've ever
seen Kate Hudson instagrams that you
guys are doing dance rehearsals together
so what does that mean you'll have to
see it's really fun and it's like I said
it's something completely different and
something that people won't expect so it
eight Hudson get involved with that or
her and see a friend um they've met I
think a little before the film but it's
been so great getting to work with her I
mean she's great and both of them are
like a dream team wouldn't learn from
somebody like Kate who's such a pro I
mean she's willing to do everything and
she's she does whatever it takes
he's shaved her head she's she's amazing
she's I mean she knows how to do
everything she's the most incredible
actor and she is probably as my biggest
inspiration in life like her an SIA like
two girls like empowerment they're
amazing
you